a naked wife got caught cheating on her
husband what's up BR hey bro how you
doing man
right all right so you you you with my
wife what's up that's my wife right
there all right that's my
wife all right I don't know what you're
digging for but that's that's my wife
right there
um and I want a divorce okay will you
give me a
divorce will you give me a divorce
please please give me a divorce I don't
want to deal with this
anymore okay um I'll turn the I'll turn
the camera
on all right here's the
key I'm done all
right I'm done I'm done with you okay I
love my daughter that's that's the only
thing that's important to me okay I have
no beef between me and you
anymore I know you're a good man it's
all good
man this this is not going to be seen by
anybody except the judge all right so
you ain't got to worry about nothing all
right I'm sorry for disturbing you have
a nice
[Music]
day oh that was so
sad
oh that guy didn't deserve that that was
so
sad this happens all the time guys and
do you see it it kind of makes you
wonder how long that's been going on if
he's to the point he's like filming it
and saying the only thing he cares about
is his daughter and you know what the
you know what the sad part about this is
she can do all of that and he probably
still won't get primary custody she can
go on Tik Tok and say he was emotion
Ally manipulative and talk all this
nonsense about
him when a lot of the times it's not
true you know women we operate on our
feelings and unfortunately when our
feelings are gone um and we didn't
really have a stable background to tell
us that our feelings don't
matter you you see women destroying
their homes for 5 seconds of
fun and these Affairs these side side B
dudes they don't pan out um I think only
5 10% of them maybe end up in a
relationship and the odds of that
relationship working is slim to none so
women will destroy a home destroy a
man all for their
feelings and it's really sad to see I
mean you could hear it in that guy's
voice he was just like broken he you
could you could just hear how devastated
was and just how tired
um and a lot of men in this country they
really do suffer in silence they they're
cheated on for years and they still
stick it out for the kids they're
disrespected for years and they still
stick it out for the kids